good morning everyone and welcome to
Alexa and Friends my name is Jeff
Blankenburg as usual and today I have
the good honor of speaking with Prem
Donna Rajan who is I'm gonna let him
introduce himself I want to make sure
that he gets that opportunity so good
morning hey good morning and appreciate
the opportunity to introduce myself to
the audience
I lead all the natural I'm part of the
Alexa AI organization or the
vice-president and Alexa and I lead all
the National understanding
work in in AI will talk a little bit
more about it as we go yeah you know but
it's it's it's all the stuff that you
like interacting with very good yeah
we're gonna die we're gonna dive deep
into that today so that the the thing
that I warned you about but I didn't
give you any background on is that I'm
gonna we like to start these sessions
with some fun questions to kind of give
the audience an opportunity to get to
know you a little bit and a little bit
about you know who you are as a person I
guess it's really the way we think about
this so I have three I have three
questions I'm gonna ask you and you have
you've had no preparation for these so I
just want to prepare you right now so so
the first question that I like to ask is
between these three which one of these
in your life is the messiest is it your
bedroom your car or your office so
that's an easy one right now it's my
autistic and I can give you a little bit
of context why if you can twist it so
once we started working from home I had
to you know my parents are staying with
us right now so my study is also a guest
bedroom so I had to go out of my study
and create a corner in my basement and
and and a quick secret that's what I am
and everybody thinks you've got a really
nice workspace set up I said yeah this
is the 36 square feet of the basement
that I've prepared for the carrier right
I make those same jokes I do a lot of
streaming obviously and I have a small
office in my house and people are like
wow it's so nice and organized like you
these devices set up behind you and
everything and this is like honestly if
you could see outside the little box
that I'm standing in it's a disaster
area there's stuff everywhere so I'm I'm
completely with you on that one
all right so so you you would say that
because you're working out of your
basement is that is that normally the
case like it is your office in an Amazon
building is it also tend to lean towards
messy or would you find something else
to be that way instead a different kind
of messy so my offices in my previous
jobs at USC Amazon they're all messy in
one aspect there's stacks of documents
and papers everywhere but that mess is
only sort of in the eyes of the people
who see I know exactly where whichever
document I want to find it so I just
want to make that that makes perfect
sense to me
I tell my wife the same thing I know
exactly where everything is don't touch
it
you'll ruin my world no I understand all
right let's move on to the second
question this is a fun one if you could
pick any superpower from any of the
comic books any comic book characters
you may have ever heard of but you only
pick one of them what superpower would
you pick does it have to be from a comic
book so actually the superpower I would
take especially because I love music is
singing oh I wish I had a singing voice
I wish I could sing because I think you
know we all know singing is sort of a
special connection to other people you
can like take them to ecstasy you can
give them like really nuanced emotional
fields itself and you can convey
yourself the ability to sing really well
yeah I like the superpower would be the
world's best singer best singer I am so
that would be that would be the
superpower but I'd be happy with just
how to sing just sing pretty well right
do you ever find yourself on a karaoke
stage or anything like that
only when I'm sure I'm never going back
to that place again so no
we will mill oh my gosh that sounds
fantastic that's okay that's great so I
that's interesting most people choose
something like flight or invisibility or
something like that but I like it I
think that's a very reasonable
superpower request is I wish I was the
best singer in the world and I'm with
you man there's a lot of power in being
able to sing well so I I think that's
that's great okay oh and there's a lot
of peer pressure at home my life was the
superb single all three of my daughters
are awesome singers they were all
trained or like right you know the
youngest ones are still being claimed
and they just super when I go there just
to clarify oh yeah that's great well at
least you have a lot of music around you
that's wonderful all right so here
here's my last question this is the one
that a lot of people have a lot of fun
with and there's no wrong answer here so
I'm always interested to see where
people go with this this is one of those
situations where you have to pick one
it'll be tempting to say oh I would just
run away but that is not an option that
you get in this question
the question is would you rather fight
one horse-sized duck or one or or one
hundred duck-sized horses forget this
question so the let's see look my if I
had to fight I'd probably take the
hundred duck-sized horses one
horse-sized duck I have no chance of
prevailing I mean unless I can run away
which you've already created so with a
hundred duck-sized horses I'm thinking
if I can maybe use crowd psychology I
sort of get one or two of them in a bad
way and then the others are like and
this guy this dude means to fight today
they run you didn't preclude them
running away so I have a better chance
of getting like 98 right see duck-sized
horses to ride like it
you're saying I'm gonna mess up a couple
of these horses and the rest of them
like whoa I don't want anything to do
with this guy I like it yeah I like it
all right that's that's a new approach I
haven't heard that one before so that's
that's that's really it's good
information not that not that we're
gonna be running into any duck sized
horses anytime soon but that's about
waking Gary but all right so I did a
little bit of research not a ton and it
seems like you have a rich history with
USC and the Trojans down there in
California do you still live down that
way yes very very good so one of the
things that I really like to unpack is
when we when we have an opportunity to
talk to someone like this that has a
rich background in understanding and
voice at speech is how did you get here
because I would imagine when you were an
undergrad or even in high school that
wasn't necessarily something that was
directly on your radar it's something
that you you veered to you found an
interest in and you've kind of focused
on since then but for a lot of people
that are watching it's always very
useful to talk about like what was your
path like how did you how did you get
here suck I don't I'd love you to start
like maybe high school maybe college but
like how did you how did what were the
decisions that you saw in your life that
kind of got you to where you are today
so my decision-making framework and I'll
answer the question but my
decision-making framework has has sort
of been relatively sort of a greedy
algorithm I sort of tended to do what I
most enjoy and what seems like will
excite me the most and and over time a
second factor came in early in my career
was all about what's the thing that
really excites me that feels challenging
intriguing that gives me an opportunity
to work with good people over time a
second factor has emerged which is
becoming more and more important which
is what can I have the most impact that
can I move the need of the most right so
those it's a very simple decision things
I consider now but to answer your
question about how did I get here you
know I was born in India
I grew up in I mean India is
multilingual but even within India I
grew up in a particularly multilingual
family because our language we speak at
home is Tamil I grew up in Maharashtra
in the city of Pune where the local
language spoken is Marathi and it's very
Marathi is all around you
but I studied in India's you know three
language education system four states
where there is no Hindi spoken which is
you learn English you learn the local
vernacular which is Marathi
and then you learn Hindi and then at
home it was tunnel so I sort of
inevitable that over time many of my
discussions with my brother my cousin
said I would often so every now and then
count hey isn't that curious this
language they sing it that way this
language they say this way or gee and
even within those languages thermal is
not in the European the other languages
are indo-european some one is the
travillian family so there were sort of
structural differences and without
realizing what we were talking about
weed off and talk about hey in one
language we seem to say come here and in
another we seem to say here come I
wonder why right so that's just the
context but in my undergraduate
engineering days I was really most
fascinated by robotics so my senior
project which took up almost all of my
senior year spare time and more was to
build a robotic arm using stepper motors
right I thought a servo controller was
too much because we couldn't do it with
our with our budget
so these stepper motors move in small
steps and good enough and I learned a
lot so I came here to study robotics and
and after coming here the faculty
members told me you know praying the
hardest problems left to solve are all
very mathematical and are you sure that
that's you know I thought you know so I
started wandering around thinking of
what I want to do so I started doing you
know information theory statistical
signal processing and then I did a
summer research internship at IBM in the
Watson Research Lab
and work on handwriting recognition oh
okay this is awesome right like it was
online handwriting recognition and I was
like this is really nice
like being able to interpret human input
convert converted into something a
computer can understand
so then after so after that that got me
on to the sort of the language
processing field if you will for my
sense
I tapped into I think an old curiosity
that had developed during childhood and
so then I joined BBN technologies as a
scientist BBN you can look it up
pioneering place in in speech and
language technologies there are many xbb
energies at amazon right now right and
so which will get to my as I close out
my story you'll see how I ended up at
Amazon too so so there was all of that
history and then but back then we were
always like this is all exciting when
are people going to use the such scale
right right and and so anyway in my
interest expanded I did handwriting
recognition OCR then either speech
recognition
I let the commercial speech engineering
team that did the first major deployment
in North America of directory assistance
out paying it was sort of a confidential
project back in those days in the late
90s anyway all of that dialogue systems
they all started coming to the portfolio
I got interested in computer vision over
time and then BBN was up and just being
a DBA and I actually worked for five
different employers without my email
changing or my phone number changing on
my office traveling right because it was
just a acquisition period over those 10
15 years in this area anyway and then I
was at Raytheon and you know the old BBN
had a little bit more of an academic
feel to it so I thought you know and
friends in academia had been asking me
for a while become would become so I
thought gee maybe it's time for the next
stage in my life I should go spend some
time in a
I went to USC absolute blast I mean I
could indulge all of my learn and be
curious leadership principle to the
racks and but also unbeknownst to me and
I and most of us when you're doing stuff
that you're passionate about you're
learning you're also delivering results
you are also having impact because
that's what keeps you going so all of
that worked out then and of many of my
many people I admired I'd worked with in
the past or just admired from the
outside in the speech and language
community and in the computer vision
community so too slowly started ending
up at this one place that you know
starts with a letter at the top of the
alphabet nice so I was thinking okay
this is interesting and so when they
reached out had a lot of conversations
and I said you know actually this could
be a super next interesting phase it
looks like they're actually delivering
impact to real world users and I thought
maybe the next phase in my life should
be AI and machine learning in the
service of humanity and so I said okay
Alexa an Amazon seemed like an awesome
place to be and what can I say it's a
pretty good map so happy-go-lucky
lifestyle right you know that make sense
I I would never I don't have nearly the
background you do in even the AI side of
things but when what Alexa came around I
was like that is a thing I need to work
on how can i how can I have an impact on
that stuff to it so it sounds like we
have a similar draw from that regard but
certainly you you've got the educational
background to to really Drive you
through all this so what did you join
Amazon this day two years ago well a
happy cake day well that's excellent so
you've been here two years that's
excellent
I am I'm coming up or late late summer
early fall will be four years for me but
but i but i agree with you i think that
this is this is one of those things that
you you either love it or it just
doesn't have a ton of interest for you
but the more and more
look around more and more developers
more and more people in general are
starting to really think deeply about
how do I use this kind of AI how do I
use this kind of technology to solve
interesting hard problems and I'm really
glad that we're here for that actually a
couple weeks ago I had menage San Juan
II on here and we were talking about ASR
and wait word detection and that kind of
stuff and so well we kind of went
through the funnel of how how Alexa
really works right if you think about
the user speaks into their device the
recording is made that is shipped off to
the cloud and then we go through the
process of speech to text and automatic
speech recognition and then I think
that's kind of where the the work lands
on your plate right that's where the
that's where the stuff that you're
working on the stuff that your team is
is researching I think that's where a
lot of it lands with I call it natural
language understanding and and when I'm
talking so good work and and when
developers when developers that I'm
speaking to in an audience when I
describe natural language understanding
I always joke that you have your own
natural language understanding engine
kind of built into your head and you a
good example of that is if you've ever
been in a relationship you know that
what you saying is not exactly what you
mean all the time so if you were to
translate the words directly right and
that you're using natural language
understanding right there to kind of
figure out like well what did they
really mean when they said I'm fine or
whatever that happens to be but it's a
it's a useful way to think about how how
natural language under understanding
really works so my question for you is
how does it work how does natural
understanding work what are the things
that that you guys are doing on your
team to really make this engine work
what is the research all that kind of
stuff yeah I make a general comment
first and then sort of talk about a
little bit of the specifics of how we do
natural language understanding in Alexa
but first to start with you mentioned oh
so I'll say you know my somewhat funny
way of putting this is between Manoj and
I we complete a lecture in somebody
right because the so we sort of pick up
where you know a mono is no doubt talked
about late word ASR etcetera etcetera
and then the ASR transcription comes to
us and now we have to say okay this is
what they said and like you pointed out
Jeff what did they mean right and so
natural language understanding generally
speaking is about sort of understanding
or extracting and representing and
acting upon the semantics of what was
said right and in the context of like a
lot of the semantics of what he said is
what does this person want to know or
what would what this person like a
lecture to do etcetera so we sort of
approach it largely from that lens but
before moving very specifically to Alexa
this one thing that you said you know
what you know people say I'm fine and
and what do you mean when you say I'm
fine
you know context is so crucial so if you
and I interact all the time and every
time I meet you and I ask you hey Jeff
how are you I'm doing great Prem and
then one day you say well I'm fine I'm
like okay something is not right with
Jeff right but if I just hear that one
thing in isolation I'm fine yeah that's
good right but if this is a guy who
always said I'm glad I'm awesome and and
then he said I'm fine I'm like okay Jeff
what's up you seem a little down which
seems like a unnatural response right -
I'm fine except if my jewelry okay whew
what about just the words it seems like
everything should be okay but when you
base it on context and previous
experiences that that gives you much
more information about what's actually
going on exactly exactly and so that of
course is the sort of the aspiration we
build towards like understanding more
context understanding remembering this
course is yes but for now just thinking
about the core of natural and
understanding in a lecture you know it's
it's you can imagine Alexa is having
like you know suite of AI services you
you said you talked about so you heard
about all the stuff on the input side
you know how the speech is brought in
but then deeper inside Alexa our
services that interpret the users
and and the technology that we use is
called natural language understanding
like you said it's also complemented by
the technology that it's called entity
resolution mm-hmm right so oh when you
and you and I are talking about Jeff
right now
we both know I'm talking about you but
in some other context it might be some
other Jeff I think there's other Jeff
I've heard maybe there are a couple
we've been for a few years yeah so at
least longer than before so that's the
so anyway so each time you speak to
Alexa raw voice is raw audio is
converted into text by the speech
recognition system the text then comes
to NLU what we call interpretations
right within internally our word for NLU
is interpretations so we first determine
the intent right the most important
thing that the user want us to you know
and let me simplify this is not exactly
a complete description but just to get
some hooks in you want to play a song
turn on a light you want to hear a joke
or you want to make some kind of comment
to Alexa
sometimes you just want to me to comment
that task we call it intent
classification understanding what the
intent is that you have right play a
song right now obviously if you just
said play a song and I know your history
of what you like etcetera I can
recommend a good song for you you know
if I know you're Led Zeppelin fan maybe
I'll say okay Jeff how about you know
stairway to heaven or something anyway
Lawson let's play stairway to heaven but
I don't know if you just play a song so
now next thing we need to do is other
mentions of what song or what artist or
what album in there so we call that
extraction like or entity extraction or
named entity recognition right these
could be contacting whether you saying
call Jeff again you know I want to make
sure I call the right Jeff
right so so things that's got a named
entity extraction extracting the name
Jeff extracting all you say play hello
by Adele
extract the song name is hello and you
know artist name is etc third we also
want to know the domain right so for
example I could say play something and
you could have something that's an audio
book by that name like Hunger Games or
Harry Potter's okay there might be the
movie by the name so I need to know
which domain you're referring to so if
you're maybe you're standing in front of
a device with a screen and you're saying
play Hunger Games a pretty song strong
signal that contexts give me a pretty
strong signal you're not expecting you
to baby the game's audio book right
you know another context might be gee
the person is 20% into the younger games
audio book and they're asking their
screen less equity bodies to play again
they probably mean continue my audio
book right so you have to figure out
which domain and he says the books
domain
lastly you do need to resolve this
extracted entity into a real-world
reference right so sometimes you say
play the stones okay okay you know is
that a game thing let's say I even
figured out that it's the music domain
but now I have to resolve the stones
into the Rolling Stones right that's
entity resolution because there could be
many matches to stones in in in any
real-world catalogue an ideal world
database but figure out which is the one
that this person meant and I want to do
that as accurately as I can then I'll
just say in multilingual systems is
sometimes a first task which is to
identify the language of the utterance
yeah and and you can and you know this
because we'll talk about it later I'm
sure this becomes particularly important
in the context of where I grew up
yeah what I told you about marketing
quality also important in the case of
countries like Japan you know you're
saying play something and the name of
the song might be an English name and
and now you have to go play that song so
multilingual that he comes in and is
increasingly as we sort of deliver on
our aspiration to serve
entire world with our services
multilingual it becomes more and more
yeah that was something I know when we
rolled out Hindi that that was one of
the first things that I really heard
about was that there's a lot of English
words that are used in India and that
they will use them at the same time you
see that a lot here in the United States
too with Spanish speakers right they'll
they'll speak in Spanish for some words
in English for other words and they'll
kind of mix it together in their
households I imagine that that has to
add a level of complexity that is
significantly more difficult than just
handling a language by itself is that is
that true it is true and you know the
interesting thing is because as you know
we are a science and engineering
organization we love complexity because
complexity means more science challenges
to solve so that's super exciting
because if it's not complex it sort of
then feels like not so interesting so
taking complexity and bringing
simplicity to the user experience of
taking something that's a complex
phenomenon which is a multilingual
utterance but bringing simplicity to it
in terms of the customer experience
which is just the same as if it were a
monolingual utterance right bridging
that gap is an awesomely satisfying yeah
so yeah so we're like bring Klingon it
that's that sounds perfect so I'm always
curious on this is and this is uh this
is something that I'm always I'm always
wondering is I getting to this stuff
because again I'm not I tend to be
focused on like how do I build a skill
how do I take advantage of the services
that you're offering um are are there
things that are viewed like in my mind
mixing two languages together seemed
like it was probably close to impossible
or really really difficult are are there
problems in the world of voice that are
I don't know identified but like
unsolvable are there things that would
just that there's no way anyone could
ever do that or is it all just that
they're really hard with enough research
it's possible so
you know I'm fundamentally a technology
optimist so my view is that in the limit
everything is solvable given time a
journey so really the question is over
what time period and what resource
constraints are we asking they're asking
that question that said there are some
things you know what people call general
AI you know part of my artificial
general intelligence like things you
just do everything because I think
humans are particularly good at
remembering certain types of context
having like really really long memories
and being able to tap into the right
memory at the right time you meet your
undergraduate classmate from I don't
know two three decades ago and you can
pick up the conversation where you last
left it and you can switch back into the
language that you and that person shared
or the dialectal way in which you talked
about or the special ways in which you
can do so there are things around and
I'm just talking about the language
there are many many other AI problems
like that that really go way up within
the short term I think there's some
things that are challenging right even
the short term regardless of the
detecting sarcasm yeah right and when
you just said yeah I know you're not
more anger at least but you could just
as well be oh yeah
well I've already solved right right and
that would be a macchiato and so it's so
hard too hard to tell or detecting you
know generally deceptive behavior
etcetera this progress made in these
things in some ways but it's hard to do
it and we also have a you know I'm just
keeping it still in the realm of
communication interpersonal
communication but we're just so good at
both reading between the lines and
reading into visual signals and and so
you know the way we say something is
reinforced so much by the expression in
our eyes or on our face
so they're just so just within the
context of interpersonal communication I
think there are lots of challenges that
is still left to be solved even in the
short term and there's such a plethora
of interesting challenges to be solved
in the short term that are valuable to
people who use the technology yeah there
may be some unsolvable problems but
that's okay I have to leave something
for my daughter to solve anyways no I
think that's great I was just a
curiosity of mine because there are
certainly some unsolved problems in
computing in general and so I was always
always curious about like the voice and
I'm sure you guys have those things that
are aspirational like sarcasm sounds
like it would be incredibly difficult so
thank you for sharing that so okay so
but that really all comes down to
research and so you have an organization
right you're vice president here at
Amazon I would imagine you have a number
of people that work in your organization
what what are the primary things that
you guys are researching what are you
what are you working on so any question
yeah all of the great opportunities at
Amazon is to sort of invested scale in
some of the hardest AI problems and
conversation they are so just give you
maybe a little bit of a quick tour
through the organization in terms of the
technical areas that we work in at the
top level a lot of our organization you
know my friend manages and mine many
others we sort of do science to the Tier
one services that we deploy right so
when we say we do interpretations we are
advancing the state of the art in
interpretations we're also running the
runtime engine that is serving all of
our customer traffic right so it's all
in one organization that makes it that
makes the transition of science advances
into into user facing capabilities it
accelerates that transition that
structure so so at the top level is just
good to keep that in mind that when we
talk about these areas we're talking
about both the science advancing those
areas and then also delivering
customer-facing services that i knit so
first of course as you might understand
you know you might imagine dialogue
management and the approach we take
there is we want to any developer in any
locale anywhere in the world to build
high value experiences using machine
learning etc and for us high value is
customers love the world customers love
it the more they want to use it the
higher the value a lot of our approach
is around self-serve around enabling
developers of making entity resolution
available to developers and and because
we wanted to deliver services to
developers it's important that we're
including both the developer experience
and helping them improve the end-user
experience so this book so that's
delivering self-serve NLU to the
developers you're very familiar with
with this aspect of our work Jeff I mean
you're making making myself so I am in
love with any resolution it is the is a
hallmark of everything that I build is
how can I best serve my customer by
getting in the answer they most likely
wanted yeah and so yeah and so so
self-serve natural language
understanding ourselves so of
interpretations to developers we want
developers to be able to build as
complex a model as they want
but keep it all as accurate as we can in
all the locales in the world we're in
we're also I take great pride in the
fact that we are a learning organization
I was known as Alexis my organization is
a learning organization and we are
driven by metrics we we like to like
Lord Kelvin said if you can't measure it
you don't understand it I hope the code
is right or something like that I
believe that very firmly if you can't
measure it we don't fully understand it
you may have an intuitive understanding
you can't always wait to measure it but
it's over time you have to get a sense
of measuring it so we have actually a
metrics research team that identifies
new ways of relating technology
performance to customer experience right
some of it is in my organization's
in other parts of Alexa but we all work
together to provide our developers and
our managers with the ability to
identify opportunities to improve the
customer experience reduce defects
launch richer experience etcetera
another area is Alexa translations we
launched this about a year and a half
ago it's already a very popular feature
with our customers I know that me and my
oldest daughter who's learning who's
been learning Spanish at school we use
it Alexa how do I say what's your name
in French go home and try it you know
try it in any of your languages how do I
say this
in that language and and actually it's
it's an interesting experience
we're also focused on language expansion
because we want to deliver LXi
experiences to everybody anywhere in the
world who wants to experience the magic
right and so we have a team focused on
accelerating internationalization of all
of ourselves that that's great to hear I
get a lot of questions from developers
about what you know what are you gonna
support my language and obviously we're
not in a position to talk about roadmap
or anything like that but it's good to
know that that's something that we're
accelerating on that's great - great to
hear oh yeah yeah absolutely and some of
the most interesting problems are at the
intersection of new languages and what
is new about that relative to what we've
done before but also interesting
research problems and how do I transfer
learning from previous languages to new
languages you know that's how you
accelerate can I do transfer learning
can I do cross-linked we're learning
etcetera another emerging areas of
research multi-sensory and interpretable
AI all of this is around making alexa
more perceptive personal more
conversational more natural to engage
with more capable last no definitely not
the least something I particularly enjoy
is the Alexa prize Grand Challenge Jeff
I'm a big fan of this yeah it's
excellent
it's an annual University competition
you know the idea here is we know this
you know doesn't matter how big our
organization is how many smart people we
have in the organization the field of
conversation is
bigger than any one organization or any
one team so we wanted to tap into sort
of the worldwide community of academic
researchers who are working in this area
and see together can we solve some of
the hardest problems in conversational
AI and so this includes all of this
includes natural language generation it
includes everything I said but it also
includes natural language generation
includes knowledge acquisition and so
it's a great place for like you know the
bright stars of tomorrow or you know
graduate students undergraduate students
to work with faculty advisors to create
novel engaging conversational
experiences we get surprising amount of
engagement from Alexa customers on the
on the chat BOTS that the university
teams put up which tell us that we're
tapping into like a common worldwide
desire to like sort of advances and do
experiments on I know the answer but I'm
going to ask you the questions so you
can answer it if people want to be able
to interact with these because there's a
bunch of amazing teams around the world
at universities that are building these
experiences that are trying to achieve
what it says the goal is what a
30-minute conversation is that a 20
minute is the is the the grand prize is
20 minutes and before going down the
path that you're asking let me just say
that and I'm very excited to announce
that we are actually the third iteration
of the prize and we are approaching
final season and so I'm looking forward
to what happens yes here do we hit that
do we hit that golden threshold that we
have said do we exceed it do we fall
tantalizingly close to it so I'm super
excited to see where it lands
so so my question is if anybody that's
watching on this video wants to know how
to try these or use them what what how
can they do that simple three words I
like so let's try it so you say Alexa
let's device is all over here on and
that that that just picks a random one
for me it lets me tap into a specific
project No picks a random one because
what we don't want happening is you know
we don't expose exactly which University
team it is that you're talking to
because that would bias the way you give
feedback
so let's say you know like Trojan alumni
am proud to say will probably be old
enough for a system built let's say if
he's not a competitor at this time but
let's say they were so it might bias
your feedback and because we use user
feedback to determine the success of the
teams we want to keep that feedback as
is possible so if you knew that for
example there was a Stanford team you
might be like oh that's terrible like I
don't like their stuff at all right just
cuz it's a competitor right it's a
arrival of another school I could see
how that would definitely influence your
view but let me just say I was one hat
on I love I think Stanford is great too
but they are rivals in in college
football and things like that right yes
that's excellent
okay so we've kind of gotten into this
the stuff that you guys are doing
research on I think that's that's all
very very cool are there when we think
about Alexa and like just the experience
that people have are can you give me
examples of how like this natural
understanding that you're working on how
how does that like maybe we don't always
realize how does that improve the
experience that customers have how does
it like maybe give me a contrast between
like how does it work how does it help
how does it change things that'd be a
good story to tell yeah yeah
so give you a couple of examples that
sort of hopefully give you a flavor of
the kinds of things we do one is a
complex what we call complex utterances
but what humans just call speaking
naturally I'm sure so so for example
somebody might come and say hey Excel
play jazz music and then the family loom
lights right that feels awesome but I
just told you about this all we do in
10th classification and then we do slots
okay
now think about this now you have two
intents and you have different entities
or mentioned in there so first you have
to detect the to intents and then
associate the right entity all of this
feels
once we parse down the problem feels
like all okay that sounds doable but
humans are capable of expressing even
simple things in complex ways so complex
things can be expressed in particularly
complex ways and
so that we launched about a year ago and
and that greatly simplifies sort of the
experience for a lot of people and we
did that because we noticed a lot of
people wanted to try the we're trying it
in and we said gee this is a friction
for our customers so we should improve
it but that friction for our customers
turned out into a challenging science
and engineering problem both developing
the solution and then architecting it in
a way you know it's one thing to solve
the science problem but then if you take
like two days to come up with the answer
the customers sort of their interest is
gone so you have to engineer a solution
right so that you're getting the answer
as soon as you ask the question or at
least as soon as it feels natural to
answer the question right so that's one
thing the second one we just talked
about
it's multilingual Alexa may be proud of
this so you know in in in India you say
Alexa what's the weather today or you
can also say Alexa haka weather care
right so you just put like a English
word in the middle of in Hindi syntactic
structure like doesn't matter and and
you can borrow these words all the time
like mmm volume increase kuru right so
this sort of Hindi carrier phrase in
some way but a lot of the content is in
English so solving that but there are
many other examples right I'm just
giving you examples of things we've you
know common things people can relate to
but think about skills we have more than
a hundred thousand skills I mean this
you tell me that actually hundred
thousand is wrong it's 110 thousand
hundred twelve thousand you have the
latest count Jeff all I know is I find
it amazing that we have a million
developers and in you know hundreds of
thousands and more than hundred thousand
skills worldwide but when you have that
many skills discovery becomes a
challenge to know so you have to
remember the name of the skill that you
have to say oh let me invoke the Lubar
skill and then ask Google to get me a
car so we we're so we're hacking away at
that problem by allowing people to just
ask for what they want and then figuring
out at the back end which skill is the
best
providing that service to them and just
completing the transaction for users so
that this big you know universe of
hundred thousand skills is not limited
by the users knowledge of eight of them
yeah because everybody knows jeopardy
right but there are so many other games
that are interesting to play and meeting
you want to play and there are me okay
the last thing and say on that front is
you know bringing back context again
right you say
Alexa get me a car and if you're looking
at a shopping screen maybe what you mean
is you are looking at different toys to
buy for your child and you decided get
me that car right right but if it's just
a non contextual thing or you find out
that you have a flight you if you've
entered your calendar information and I
know you were plane to catch in two and
half hours and you say get me a car I
say oh dude wants right cap right and so
so that kind of thing that naturalness
people just they you know and I take
great pride in the fact that when people
take it for granted and then even at
social events or parties and people ask
and I say okay you know this is why it's
challenging and they say oh my god I had
no idea was that all those challenges so
it give me great pride when people just
take it for granted that AI works this
way because then it feels to me we have
done it just right they're getting the
experience they want and they don't even
have to think about how complex it is to
do know I think that's that's awesome
that's very very cool
so I CASP was was last month did you did
you an opportunity to attend some of the
sessions that were there I guess no
because uh you know I have to tell you
one of the challenges in over years I I
did get I was very involved in planning
some of the things leading up to Atticus
but was very much looking forward to
attending some of the sessions but you
know we all know what the challenge the
last two three months have been and I
felt I had to spend more time with my
team making sure I was addressing the
challenges there
facing doing what I can so yeah it's um
you know what can I say there was a time
when you know missing hi Cass but you
know other conferences would be oh my
god how could I do that and now it's a
little bit like a luxury man next year
I'm really going yeah I think the prices
and the attendance of conferences next
year are gonna be out of control
like I run a conference myself that we
had to cancel this year and I imagine
because everybody missed the next year's
even gonna be a much bigger demand so so
related to that though like can you talk
to me about Alexa conversations and kind
of how you're improved thinking about
conversational AI yeah yeah yeah so
actually the Alexa conversations
workshop was the workshop that I wanted
my my team to do there because I think
it's an important thing and when I said
I was involved in some of the crap that
was one of the things I was very
interested in so just to frame what is
Alexa conversations you know skills
developers can develop skills today you
know using the process we have but as
we've been thinking about how to make
this process simpler for developers
remember I told you like we want to make
the developer experience better and
enable them to tell you better and user
experiences as well improve the end-user
experience so that context Alexa
conversations is a deep learning based
approach like so many things today for
creating conversational experiences but
where we're using machine learning is to
reduce the number of lines of code they
have to write big reduction but let me
just say it's a by a factor of sometimes
both because of reusability and because
of the way in which we've simplified the
process of developing a new skill but
also by reducing the amount of training
data that's needed right and to reduce
the amount of training data real
everything deep learning in multiple
ways whether it's transfer learning
whether it's data generation
automatically from
what the users give us and also just new
innovations and stay tracking state
trajectory etc so that's Alexa
conversations only examples of the early
example of an extra conversation just to
put give a sort of a flavor of the kind
of application that's enabled by it
early example of Alexa conversations is
the night out function that was
announced I was cool yeah last three
bars and the MV yeah and we have to
cancel this year's beam are still
something I yeah I was so looking
forward to talk about things that you
were looking forward to that
gonna do things a philosophy nice right
away so the Nidal functionality is you
know imagine family planning a night out
and they first started okay I want to go
book figure out which movie to watch and
then maybe pick a restaurant to eat and
maybe I need to arrange transportation
to go there etcetera etcetera now
instead of you having to specifically do
each one of these tasks wouldn't it be
great
the thought thinking back that was
wouldn't it be great if you just I want
to plan a night out and then Alexa takes
care of all the transitioning between
different skills required to complete
your mission for that evening and you
just keep articulating sort of what you
want and what you'd be interested in
doing or maybe it's not a movie maybe
it's going to a museum and then you
ability to buy the museum tickets that
transaction is completed and then really
transportation to go there or do you
need parking so things like that all of
that packaged into one you can have you
can interact with night out today it
takes care of all of course these are
challenging times to use my pals who you
can yeah right but what we're looking
you know but you know it won't always be
this way there will be a time when we're
all planning my lots of nights out again
and I'm sure just like you were saying
conference prices might grow up I think
number of people design to go out will
greatly increase last thing I'll just
say it is Alexa conversational also set
Stage four Riu component reusability in
addition to data generation to simplify
and reduce the burden on the developer
for an agenda for creating lots of data
we do it on the back end there's also
these ability and data we have reduced
in many examples working with developer
partners and very grateful for them for
partnering with us data has been reduced
by a factor of ten in many cases
achieving the same or better levels of
performance and reusability is improving
this by a factor of three the amount of
code that you need to write excellent
excellent
all right so so we talked a little bit
about night out which is I remember the
first time that I saw that I was just
blown away that like we can piece all
this stuff together and really allow
those conversations to happen where we
can just kind of dig in I I would use to
this example of something that I aspire
for and we don't need to get in this I'm
just gonna share this with you is the
idea that I could say to Alexa Alexa I
need a dentist's appointment and she
goes okay you have an appointment
scheduled for next Tuesday like the the
context and the work behind the scenes
to make all of that happen is remarkable
it has to talk to my insurance company
has to talk to my dentists systems it
has to talk to all the high places but
man what what a world it will be when I
can just do that and it happens and I'll
have to make a call and wait on hold and
look at compare schedules ups is amazing
even in the context of night out Jeff
you know as you're doing this context
that you just mentioned carrying over
context from one conversation in the
next like maybe you asked for are there
any Mexican restaurants what are the
nearby in Mexican restaurants so maybe
you asked about a movie where it's
playing then if the next thing is that
you're booking a car you don't want to
have to say the location of the movie
theater of the restaurant that should
just be carried over by Alexa for you
and we do it now that's in the night
scene so totally with you context is
king in many ways so as we talk about
things like conversation which rely on
things like AI there's always a
conversation about fairness in
I know this is something that's they
don't near and dear to you so how are we
addressing questions around that how are
we trying to mitigate bias and things
like that yeah so first you know the
fact that fairness in AI is an
increasingly important question and it
has as rightfully increasing amounts of
attention worldwide across many equities
is is also testimony to the success of
the AI in the sense that AI is
everywhere so now that it's getting
everywhere or into more and more places
we now have the responsibility of making
sure a AI works equally well for
everyone right that's crucial
and so the underlying thrust of our work
in fairness both that we're doing
internally and that responding
externally is to make sure that AI works
equally well for everyone it will take a
lot of effort it's not going to be just
us it's going to be a broad you know
public private academia kind of
concerted effort nonprofits will be
involved industry academia interest
groups right representing the different
kinds of considerations in fairness one
of the ways we are addressing it of all
the areas of AI I think fairness
requires really a multi sector
participation so one of the ways early
ways in which I started addressing it
after joining Amazon was we launched
this partnership with NSF to do fund
programs in the finest Feria it's about
20 million in grants half of it comes
from Amazon half of it from NSF the the
funded projects you know selection is
left entirely to NSF we simply provide
the funding our interest wasn't seeing
the development of a funded academic
research community that is addressing
these problems and providing new
insights that everyone corporations
government everybody can use to develop
better AI for all of us
the so ensuring fairness and algorithms
the systems that incorporate them using
AI to promote equity in society
etc some couple of examples if you're
interested projects that being funded
you can go to the Amazon science blog
excellent website where you can get a
list of all the complete set of projects
and who's working on them etcetera but
one example that caught my attention as
I was looking through it was mmm we've
known for quite some time that you know
certain ethnic groups have higher rates
of heart disease than others and
concomitant with that is a higher rate
of post operational issues complications
that arise and so the question is how do
you improve this how do you make it more
equally performant for all of these for
all of these ethnic groups are different
different cohorts of people the other
thing we don't another project is we
don't have a sense of the disparity how
much of that disparity is due to
biological factors so how much of it is
due to socio-economic factors how much
is due to sort of differences in quality
of care across different geographies or
even different training for doctors and
nurses and care personnel so the project
is trying to bring AI tools to you know
rich electronic health record data set
to sort of characterize the create new
insights into how is all of this what
might be the most salient root causes
and how can we address them etc the
other thing I'll say is we also
participate in multi sector initiatives
like the partnership on AI oh can I ask
you I represent I represent Amazon on
the board of Pai and you know Pai works
to generate its you know there are
nonprofits there's academic members on
the board company representatives on the
board corporation representatives and
Pai works to generate sort of best
practices development and deployment of
practical AI technology among the many
things that they do Pai is developing a
sense of sort of the future of AI across
many different spectrums whether it's
documentation for AI and other things
but the
that I in this context it's worth
pointing out is best practices for the
development and deployment of ethical AI
technology so I think we feel like
that's the way to advance build multi
sector partnerships build a national or
even international coalition around
these important issues try to fund it so
that the people who are closest to the
issues are developing the insights that
can guide us the best make those
insights available to everyone because
fairness is important enough all of
these insights should be shared and then
hope that everybody uses these insights
to develop the best systems that they
can that's excellent
all right so we are we're coming up
close on time we've been talking for
almost an hour and wow I have I have two
more things for you I'm gonna do the
quick one first and then I'm gonna the
longer answer one we'll leave for the
very end one of the things that I like
to ask people is how many Alexa devices
do you have in your house they have to
actually be plugged in I got caught on
this question one since somebody sent
100 and I said you don't have 100 and
they said no I have a closet and I
there's like actually like 60 devices in
the closet that I use for giveaways and
things so I don't know how many you
actually have plugged in and then you
actually use I'm glad you said that
because mm-hmm I don't have 100 but I do
have seven that are plugged in and we
use you know my daughter's rooms our
bedroom dining room living room office
all of that right and it's great because
you know the way we all work is to get
exercise we go to the gym but otherwise
we're lazy we don't want to walk around
the house right so it's awesome to drop
in on my daughter and say hey it's time
for dinner you wanna I do it every night
so we actually made chicken tikka masala
last night for dinner
with some anonymous delicious and you
know I had to use an ounce I do it every
night I make dinner and then I have to
announce this to everybody like come on
downstairs it's time for time for dinner
so I was doing like funny voices and
stuff like that so that's good a legacy
from your India to go with Amit Shah
twonny to India for a little while he
took me around Delhi and we had some of
the most fantastic food I've ever had I
don't have a broad exposure to in
in food in my life but the times that
I've had it man it's it's fantastic and
so I'm trying to bring that into the
house a little bit you can use my family
to some of those flavours they've never
had before all right so the last
question I have for you and I hinted at
this when we we talked earlier you
you've worked out a lot of really
interesting natural understanding
projects and technologies for alexa is
is there one you can call out as like
the thing you're the most proud of or
the the thing that you you kind of hold
up is like I'm so excited that I was
able to do this so just what I'd say is
this so the thing that I'm most excited
about and therefore the most proud about
is coming we will be announcing it later
this year can't talk about it now as you
know but of the things that we have done
the one that I'm most proud of a couple
of things that I'm very proud of you
know most is such a hard question to
answer oftentimes one is the launch of
Alexa in Hindi partly because it relates
back to my origins in India you know one
of my undergraduate classmates came for
the launch event on his own he was so
excited to see that one of his
classmates is part of so and so our
sense of pride comes from also the group
of people whose opinions we care about a
lot there are friends that people go but
also because we made Alexa capable of
multilingual utterances it was not done
before second thing I'm really really
proud of is this partnership that I just
mentioned that we launched through the
NSF to drive a fairness in AI research I
was so delighted that we as a company
would invest that money and leave the
selection process entirely to the NSF
and say look what we really want to do
is drive research in this area and we
want to understand what people find out
and we want to learn from it so those
are two things I'm but honestly the
customer facing hurdles the ones are
most excited about are the ones that
we're working on now and you know I know
and I feel like we need to make the rest
of the world make more noise about that
stuff you we talked earlier about how
you could have multiple utterances in
the same state
and be able to parse them and say like
turn the light off and play this song or
something like that that's actually
something I until you and I planned out
this this conversation that was not even
something that I knew about was that
that was possible right I I had tried it
a long time ago and it didn't work and
so then I it never became part of my
vernacular and so I feel like we need to
be making loud announcements about this
stuff and let the world know like hey
this stuff is possible now it's so great
yeah yeah you know it's like being in a
festival right Jeff there's just so many
attractions that and all of them are
screaming equally loudly at you so the
one that you go to with an Alexa it's
just so much happening in Texas so much
excitement we're launching so many
things I think every collection of users
goes to the ones that they hear the most
about at that particular thing and
you're right but maybe the other thing
is also just over time as people start
figuring oh there's so many things I can
do with this and as you know there's
more smart home devices and there's more
happening etc I think all of these our
goal is not to promote the use of any
one of these features but to build all
of these towards creating this totally
natural interaction right so each one of
these I see it as a step function and
one way of looking at it is are more
people using Alexa and are more people
as a fraction happier with their use of
Alexa and on those metrics I get super
excited about the data we see all right
well pram I can't thank you enough for
coming and having this conversation with
me today this has been just absolutely
outstanding I learned a lot and I'm
hoping that our audience picked up a
bunch of useful things as well between
the partnership where AI and a lot of
the other things that you talked about I
think this is uh this is really great
that we're able to share all of this
with the people that care so deeply
about Alexis so thank you for being here
today Jeff thank you thanks to the
audience for their time listening to
this I totally enjoyed this conversation
like you said I couldn't believe that an
hour has passed by and and you know I
was almost at the place where I forgot
the duck and the horses I hope there's
no nightmare fuel there for you but I
want to thank everybody for tuning in
thank you so much we'll be here again
next week I'm bringing some people in
from our product team to talk about some
of the cool stuff that they have at work
as well so thank you again Prem thank
you
everybody for being here and we'll see
you soon thanks everyone bye-bye thank
you